only need 10 clients at a thousand bucks  a month to make a hundred thousand here  if i were smart i would probably do  something more around branding and  awareness because it's a much easier  deliverable it's a little bit harder to  sell but if you get people to agree that  they just want to be active on tick-tock  they want to be active on instagram and  they're not they know they should and if  the price is right they'll agree to  doing it as long as they see that  there's activity there you can explain  to them that people are going to search  them look for them and then call them  and so they're getting shadow effect  through social media that are happening  as a result of what you're doing but  it's not direct but by selling it that  way you're going to keep expectations  though they'll stay much longer and